Dancing with the Stars juniors and I was
just hanging with the judges about
schmear coughs Pete many more and Adam
Griffin and the first thing I learned
for the contestants maybe smaller but
the wardrobe department still goes big
what's so cute is these are the regular
human size costumer and then back here
it's like isn't it so look at that it's
going to work in this size 40 are you
kidding me but the Olympic figure skater
and season 26 mirror ball champ says
adjusting to his new role as judge is no
joke it's so different because for the
last like 28 years of my life I've been
the judge II and the judge her I just
can't deal Emmy winning choreographer
Mandy is pulling double-duty on the show
choreographing the opening numbers and
judging her strategy you have to have a
little bit of kid gloves
but I've also found that kids respond
better when you're authentic as far as
technique goes I'm gonna be like you
know what we have a little bit of work
to do but the toughest part of the job
for the two-time mirror ball chant val
is when the pint-sized contestants get
sent home that's the hardest part of the
show by far and there's no easy way to
handle it they are genuinely so
surprised because like this is the best
summer camp ever for them I love this
show
well isn't the only emotion flowing
through the ballroom Adam admits there's
some jealousy at the judge's table I
always liked Val the last time you said
that one-liner
I like wanting to punch you in the face
is so good me before this season is over
I will punch him in the face yes
Oh for TV that's good for ratings yeah
not in front of the kids though no it's
juniors yeah you got it
this Sunday show on ABC is our favorite
Disney night lots of good song
[Music]
[Applause]